come to this video playing at mundo with
black was that Grand Master Edward
andreia ok I have absolutely never heard
of this guy ok I've had a very lucky win
in the accelerated dragon the game
before let's do it again Jim another
will expert him I know that this kind of
exists but I don't know any details
quick edge for zar possible analyzes
with a friend like oh my god so long ago
it's not even true yeah ok so isn't
actually not canceling long he's
cancelling short hmm ok
mm-hmm so I cannot take this and that's
true but one thing was I what I just
wanted to have the rook in the game
maybe he can they're probably not
thinking taking on f6 95 or something
but that doesn't look right yeah 97 at
the end he's putting his knight on d5
that's always an issue and okay
yeah I just drew k1 him he will just
play with k1 and then put pressure on my
porn don't feel a really nice
continuation say I way to somehow get
those those minor pieces traded that
would help and ninety seventy can take
play 95 it's just it just doesn't this
is just not noise
yeah 86 is just an extremely yeah not a
move you want to play so actually t
actually doesn't mind the trades okay I
felt that this does help me I mean not
like I'm better or anything but compared
to the position with with heavy pieces
with with more minor pieces on I think
I've gained a little bit okay anyway so
if i take this it'sit's again some lucky
queen Trevor what Ruby form and yeah
that is a queen trap
ok so let's get out of this this chick
that's always annoying yeah this this
should be roughly equal I don't think I
can be much worse EF if anything at all
hmm let's do this if he goes ok one I
have Ruby aid
before I think reform I mean there
should be some way for her to to get to
a complete equality by just raiding many
porns but currently I don't don't see
anything great fam there's always also
the check check on b6 check on a seven
that can be technically a problem for
wide um yeah just look see fire from
taking both pawns okay I mean I'm not
threatening to take the a5 pawn but okay
yeah here if I just take that at the end
he will take it seven
I wonder if I can be six is an option
here that does anything yeah probably
not so let's just take it so i can take
here and you now does he threaten
anything here queen not really this for
example is playable time morning
check
yeah yeah I can go to h6 it was my
intention Queen d2 of corset
Queen g2g five would be a pretty cheeky
way to play yeah but why not actually
groups not the king please I'm in taking
d5 and I have Quincy one check yeah I
can actually take with the Queen I don't
I don't see anything particularly wrong
with that see I don't know does he have
anything there don't see it rotate so
checking the phone
most biggest issue is the time in the
lack of time actually but what is that
it's not even a chick hammered check
here maybe okay check check no I wanted
to go to f6 of course nonsense check
check there are offered no check I'm
gonna pawn up you and you aren't very
quick you know check check white
forfeits on town was a bit of a gamble
but damn and no no draw okay so tough
game yeah I didn't like my position here
so much the a form looks weekend I like
a bit of experience with those positions
Jim I kind of played the conservative
moves at least stockfish doesn't hate it
initially Knight b6 yeah you know I i
saw that i can play the night but i'd
simply didn't feel like playing without
this bishop he and so on it was a very
conservative maybe of it and i saw that
this this structure is good effect this
kind of structure from the maracas avoid
years ago Black is always ok I think
here it should end in a drawer somehow
check it did not send not materialize
yeah this I think just doesn't work I
can take it you might still have this
draw it check yeah I was panicking a
little busy with Queenie five probably I
have something better Queen to FK okay
Queen tf4 yeah that looks good now I'm
threatening this and he doesn't have a
check himself yeah okay then in the end
it was a typical scramble of him where a
quicker player um yeah wins ok guys
thanks for watching